The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, why don't
we go ahead and get started.
So today what we
want to do is start
thinking a bit about evolution
in finite populations.
And of course, what
we mean by that,
is evolution in populations
where we have to really think
about stochastic dynamics.
And now in general,
just like in the context
of gene networks within
cells, the situation
where we have to worry
about stochastic dynamics
is in the small
number kind of limit.
What's perhaps surprising
about evolution
is that they're always--
the small numbers
are always important.
Even if you're in
a large population,
I'd say 10 to the 9 individuals,
if you want to study evolution,
then you're interested in
cases where new mutants will
arise in the population.
And kind of by definition,
those new mutants
start out as kind of a single
member of the population.
Which means that in the
context of evolution,
we always have to think about
stochastic type dynamics.
Now the basic model that we're
going to use in this class
is the Moran process,
which is a model that
fixes population size.
And then instead of having
discrete generations, where
all the individuals
are reproducing
at the same time-- which
is what you might have seen
in the Wright-Fisher
process-- instead,
we're going to think
about the situation
where it occurs more stepwise.
In the sense that individuals
reproduce one at a time.
And then we contract the
dynamics of the population.
So we're going to think about
both the situation where we're
trying to understand neutral
dynamics, when we're tracking
the composition of a population
when the fitness of individuals
is equal or nearly equal.
But because in
stochastic dynamics,
there are interesting
things that happen.
But then we'll get
into the question
of non-neutral evolution.
And really, we want to
consider both halves of that.
All right, so in many cases,
in the context of evolution,
we're interested in, or
focused on beneficial mutants.
Now for those
beneficial mutants,
one of the basic things
we're going to find
is that even beneficial mutants
will typically go extinct.
It doesn't mean that they're
not important over the long run.
But it does mean that
there is a very real sense
that randomness is
dominating the life of even
beneficial mutants.
And then finally,
if there's time,
we will discuss this idea
of Muller's ratchet, which
is basically pointing
out that if there
are deleterious mutants or
mutations in the population,
those deleterious
mutations can in some cases
spread and fix in
the population.
And when that
happens, you can have
a decrease in the fitness
of a population over time.
And this is particularly
a strong effect
for small populations,
because small populations,
they're not as effective,
what you might call filters,
for selection.
And so what we
want to do is start
by thinking about
this Moran process.
And the key feature
here is that we're
going to have a constant
population size, constant N.
And that's not
because we believe
that real populations always
have a fixed population size,
but rather, we want to
try to get some intuition
in this simple model.
And then of course, it's
reasonable to ask, well,
which aspects of the
mathematics or intuition
we develop are going to
change as a result of allowing
fluctuations in the
total population size?
But I think there's
a lot of value
in starting out by analyzing
the simplest model that you can.
So what we're going
to think about
is a situation where we
have a population composed
of N individuals.
And for now we'll just
consider two types, A and B.
And this is going to be a
model for asexually reproducing
populations.
Constant N, asexual.
What that means
is, in particular,
that we're going to assume
that an A individual can
lead to two individuals.
Similarity, a B individual
can lead to two B individuals.
Right, so you can think about
this as, for example, a model
for how microbial
populations may evolve.
And for now, we will not
consider any mutations.
All right, so we're going to
think about the process of
assume that those mutations
are already there.
So A and B could be different.
They could have, for
example, different--
they could be different
at some point mutation
side of some gene that
is relevant for growing
a low glucose
concentration, for example.
OK?
So here we're going to--
so this is birth slash
division, and in particular
here we're going to, for now,
assume no mutation.
So we'll assume that
A's always give birth
to A's, and B's always
give birth to B's.
We'll follow the
nomenclature from the reading
that you guys did last night,
Martin Nowak's book, chapter
six, where we're going
to think about-- we're
going to assume that there
are initially i A individuals,
and therefore, N
minus i B individuals.
Now we'll assume that the basic
process for the-- in this Moran
process is that you have
reproduction, or birth, that's
proportional to fitness.
And then the
resulting kind of what
you might call a daughter
cell replaces one member
of the population at random.
So there's birth and
then replacement.
And indeed we'll assume
that replacement,
that the daughter
cell, for example,
could even replace the
mother cell, if we want.
So this is just the birth.
So A is going to lead--
there's going to be two As,
and this new A will
have to replace
one of the other individuals
in the population,
to keep constant
population size.
All right.
Are there any questions
about the basic model?
OK.
So that, in principle,
here we can use this model
to try to understand both
neutral and non-neutral
evolution.
But let's start out by thinking
about the neutral case.
So in particular, the
fitness, rA is equal to rB.
Now what I want to do
is, given the rules we
just kind of laid out for you,
let's assume that i over n
is equal to one third.
So for now, we'll say, OK a
third of the population is A,
2/3 is then B.
And we can think about
these probabilities
of going from i to i
plus 1, as compared
to going from i to i minus 1.
So these are the probabilities
that in one cycle of birth
replacement, the number of A's
goes up one or goes down one.
Can you ever go up two or three
or four in the Moran process
in one step?
No.
Because each step is always
one birth and one replacement.
So you can move, at most, one.
Do you always move--
does i change always?
No.
And what we want to
know is the probability
of going from i to i plus 1,
as compared to the probability
of going from i to i minus one.
The ratio of these
probabilities is equal to what?
We're considering a case
where the A's and B's have
the same fitness,
so they're somehow
equal per capita probability
of being chosen to reproduce.
But there's-- but we're not
in a symmetric population
distribution, right?
So 1/3 of the population
is A, 2/3 is B.
So I'll give you 20 seconds
to think about this.
All right, do you
need more time?
Everybody nod or shake.
Do you need more time?
OK.
I'll give you another 10
seconds, because it's--
Let's go ahead and
see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
We have a wide range of
different answers here.
OK, perfect.
This is exactly the
situation that we hope for.
So turn to your neighbor.
You should certainly be
able to find somebody
that disagrees with you.
So if the first person you
turn to agrees with you,
try to find somebody
else talk to.
All right, why don't we
go ahead and reconvene.
I know that there was quite
a lot of disagreement,
so that means that you
guys will probably not
be able to converge in
this one minute time frame.
But let me just see, let
me see if anybody's mind
was changed by their neighbors.
All right, let's re-vote.
Ready, three, two, one.
OK, all right, so
it's pretty much
the same as where
we started, maybe.
All right.
OK I would say-- does
anybody want to volunteer
what their neighbor said?
I know what your neighbors said.
So tell us.
AUDIENCE: OK, so if you--
so I would say it's E.
And the reason is that--
so there are two cases.
In the first case, both the
number A and B stay the same.
Right, for example, A
gets born and A dies.
So you first decide, is the
pop-- is the number of A and B
going to change, or is
it not going to change?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Once you've
decided that it's not
going to change-- I'm sorry.
Once you've decided that
it is going to change--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --then you
just want to know, OK,
then what's the probability
that you just choose A to change
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then the
probability that A--
you choose--
PROFESSOR: OK.
But you haven't said anything
about replacement yet.
So I'm-- replacement should
be-- because certainly,
we're talking about the ratio of
the probability that the number
of A goes up, as compared to
of A goes down.
Right?
So we've already, in some
ways, excluded the cases
where the number of A
individuals doesn't change.
And in your-- what
you just told us,
you're asking about
the probability
that individuals are going
to be chosen to reproduce.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, but I guess
all I'm saying is
that there're going to be
two halves to this, right?
So you have to think
about the probability
that an individual is being
chosen to reproduce, and also
the probability that a
particular type of individual
will be chosen to get replaced.
So it's the-- there's somehow
a balance of those two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right,
because in this case--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] replace--
PROFESSOR: --replace, this is--
right, death, slash-- right.
And I should maybe just
highlight-- if you want,
you could call--
replacement-- I mean,
this is just a nice way
of saying death, right?
Death--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you can.
I mean, [? the point ?]
[? is ?] once you've ruled out--
once you say, OK, the
populations are going
to change, then if you choose an
A to reproduce, a B has to die.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK,
once you've already--
AUDIENCE: If an A is
chosen to reproduce,
and an A is chosen
to die, then--
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah, right.
But, OK, I think I understand
what you're saying.
But we-- you still have
to keep track of there
are the two sides.
There's the replace--
there's the birth,
and the replacements.
And we have to figure out how
the relative probabilities
or rates that those
two things happen.
Does somebody want to make an
argument for something else?
I mean, we'll see how this
plays out in a moment.
AUDIENCE: I want to argue for C.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So take the numerator.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In order to
go from i to i plus 1--
so we're going to
take two individuals
from the population.
We need one of them to be
type A, that's the one that's
going to reproduce.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And the other to
be type B, the one that's
going to die.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we get
the product of those--
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
OK.
And we can actually just be
more-- be explicit about this.
OK, so the probability-- in
one cycle, the probability
that you go from
i to i plus one.
That requires that
two things happen.
One is that you choose an
A individual to reproduce.
And what's the probability
that you choose
an A individual to reproduce?
AUDIENCE: It's going
to be i over N.
PROFESSOR: i over N. So
we have i over N. Right,
so this the probability
that A reproduces.
And then for i to go
from-- to increase by one,
requires not only that
an A individual is chosen
to reproduce, but that
a B individual is chosen
for replacement, or death.
And what's the probability
that that's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: That's N
minus i all over N.
PROFESSOR: N minus
i, all over N. OK.
So this is the probability
that in one cycle
you're going to go
from i to i plus 1.
Now of course it's
not-- we haven't
said what the probability
of staying in i is,
but this is the probability
that i will increase by one.
Do we agree?
And indeed, where is it
that we've assumed-- where
is it that we've assumed
neutrality in this calculation?
That A and B have equal fitness?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Just take the
probability of reproducing
to be about-- or, the--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
So indeed, we've-- this
probability that A reproduces,
we've assumed that it's just
simply i over N. Whereas,
if it were non-neutral we'd
have to write something else.
Maybe we'll figure out what
that's going to be in a moment.
But it's in here that
we've assumed that.
Incidentally, you
could write down
a reasonable model similar
to the Moran process,
where differences
in fitness show up
instead of here, in the
probability of reproduction,
you can have it as a difference
in probability of death,
or being replaced.
But this is the most
maybe intuitive way
of thinking about it.
And this is very
similar to, for example,
what happens in a,
what you might call,
a turbidostat, where you keep
constant population size.
And as the cells divide other
cells are randomly sucked out.
So I'd say that this
Moran process is really
a theoretical kind
of implementation
of what you could
do experimentally,
is this turbidostat.
Which is like a
chemostat, instead
of keeping constant dilution
rate, you fix population size.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So do we care about
the step of, OK, first A
reproduces.
Then, from the pool
of new individuals--
because you're going
to have N plus 1, so--
PROFESSOR: OK, so all right.
I think maybe I wasn't
totally clear on this.
OK so, you have N
individuals here.
What you're going
to do is you're
going to choose one
of them randomly,
maybe proportional to
fitness for reproduction.
And then, but then,
from this original N,
you choose one of
them for death.
So it's not-- you're not, yes.
It's not-- so the daughter
cell is not allowed to--
AUDIENCE: Die.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The daughter cell always
replaces somebody,
but it could've been
the mother cell.
If we're thinking about this
in the context of cells.
So we haven't yet figured out
which answer is which, right?
But we can go ahead.
OK, this is the probability
that A reproduces,
and over here, this
is the probability
that a B individual is replaced.
Right?
What we can do is,
we can ask, well
what's the probability that
we go from i to i minus 1?
Well it's the exact kind
of same calculation,
except now what we
want to know is,
we want to know the
probability that a B is
chosen for reproduction.
And what is that going to be?
Somebody?
N minus i, right, the
number of B individuals
divided by the total
number of individuals.
So this is the probability
that a B reproduces.
And then what's the
probability that A--
that an A type
individual will be chosen
for replacement or death?
That's just i over N. The
number of A individuals divided
by the total population size.
All right, does everybody
agree with the two calculations
that we just did?
Let's re-vote.
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
All right, see, you know,
if we do the calculation,
we can convince you.
So indeed, these are equal,
these two probabilities.
Right, and this is funny.
Because on the one hand it's
like blindingly obvious,
but then the other hand,
you get yourself all tied up
in knots thinking about it.
So I don't understand why or
how those two statements can
be true at the same
time, but they are.
So this is indeed a
random walk in i space,
number of A individuals.
And it sort of has to
be, because these things
are neutral.
The fact that i over N
is not equal to a half
doesn't matter, because these
two terms kind of cancel.
But indeed, all of the things
that you know have to be true
based on the fact that A
and B have equal fitness,
they're going to not work if
this thing were not equal to 1,
if these two probabilities
were not equal.
So any of these other answers
would lead to things that you
would clearly agree are
going to be nonsensical,
if you think through
the consequence of this.
And we're going to
do one right now.
All right, let's imagine
that we start-- so here's
the number of A individuals, i.
I apologize that that's
the nomenclature we
have for a number
of A individuals,
but we want to be consistent
with Martin's book.
Now let's say this
is N and let's say
we start out at some i here.
The question is, what's the
probability that B fixes?
I want to make sure I write
down some reasonable options.
So what we want to know is
the probability that B fixes,
and that means that it
takes over eventually.
That B, we'll say eventually.
In the Moran process
with neutral dynamics.
AUDIENCE: I's the
number of A, right?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
i is the number
of A individuals.
I'm going to give you
seven more seconds.
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
All right, so we have-- it's
kind of mostly split between
C's and D's.
Although I'd say a majority
of the group is going to say--
is saying that it's going to be
D. All right, can-- all right,
and this is the distinction
between the probability that B
fixes and that A fixes.
I'm not trying to
be super tricky,
but I just want to make
sure that you keep track
of A's and B's.
And in particular,
as i increases,
the probability that A
fixes should go up or down?
Verbally, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Up.
PROFESSOR: Up.
This here-- over here is a bunch
of A's, here is a bunch of B's.
So if you have a
larger here, than you
should be more likely to fix
the A individuals, vice versa.
So in particular, this-- the
probability that B eventually
fixes is going to be this,
whereas the probability that A
will fix eventually is just
going to be 1 minus that,
it's i over N.
So this is indeed what was
pointed out in the book.
All right, and can somebody
give an argument, verbally,
for why the-- I mean,
this is a result,
that if you think
about in the right way,
you can just verbally say
why it has to be this.
Rather than writing down all
the equations that-- so why
is it that the probability
that A will eventually fix
has to be equal to i over N?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] book.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, perfect.
AUDIENCE: So at this given
time, there are N individuals--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
And there will always
be N individuals,
because we're keeping it--
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah, right.
Their descendents,
at some point,
the descendents
of one of them is
going to take over
the whole population.
That's a given.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And that's fine.
It's at first glance
kind of surprising
but, it's just the nature of--
if you imagine that they all
were individually tagged,
right, so it wasn't just
that we had two types, A
and B. But if they were
all color coded
using rainbow colors,
then you could
keep track of them.
And one of the individuals
will eventually fix.
Now, OK, and then what's next?
AUDIENCE: So there
are i individuals
that are type A,
so the probability
that this one individual
[INAUDIBLE] will fix.
PROFESSOR: And then there is
one ingredient in that argument
that you didn't say, but
I'm sure is in your mind.
Which is, how is it that
the probability-- so
among these N
individuals, right?
One of them will eventually fix.
And what's the
probability that each one
will be the lucky ancestor
for all of the population?
AUDIENCE: So it's
equally distributed.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's just 1 over N, right?
So the idea is there are N
individuals in the population,
they're all identical.
We know that
eventually one of them
is going to take over
the population, just
due to random
stochastic dynamics.
What that means is that
each individual has
a probability of 1 over N of
taking over the population.
And this is very important.
So each individual has a 1
over N probability of fixing.
And that's assuming that
everybody in the population
has the same fitness.
And that's just by symmetry.
But then of course,
you can also say, well,
you know if the probability of
each individual is 1 over N,
then the probability that one of
these i individuals takes over
is going to be i over N.
AUDIENCE: The
generalization [INAUDIBLE]
reproducing organisms is
that [INAUDIBLE] organisms
every individual is probably
the ancestor of [INAUDIBLE].
Like ever individual
takes [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, all right.
OK, now you want to
allow for recombination.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: I mean, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So yes, there are several
important aspects of sex.
But one of the major ones
is the recombination.
And so if you have
enough recombination,
then everybody will
contribute-- well, everybody.
Then there will be-- then
many, many individuals
will contribute to
the [? lineage. ?]
What you often will
hear people talk about
is the ancestral Adam
and the ancestral Eve.
And that-- and what are people
referring to about that?
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: An individual
with the-- an individual
that [INAUDIBLE]
early on [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, right.
So there's this
idea-- OK, so I don't
want to get too much into
the sexual-- sexually
reproducing populations
because that's
covered more in other classes.
And it's a totally different
models you would typically use.
But I think the simplest
way to think about some
of this is just that there's
some part the genome that
does not have recombination
in the same way.
So it's simpler.
What part of the
genome is that in us?
AUDIENCE: Y chromosome.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the Y chromosome, and that
means that in principle you
could track the dynamics
along the male lineages.
So there are all these studies,
whatever, Genghis Khan, maybe
lots of us are descendants of.
Right, because he had lots of
wives, or something like that.
So his Y chromosome
supposedly occupies
a non negligible fraction
of the population.
OK, so but then what
about-- what's the other,
yeah, so on the female side?
What would be the equivalent?
AUDIENCE: Mitochondria.
PROFESSOR: Mitochondria.
Right.
So in principle,
you can-- so I think
for an awful lot of
these studies you can--
the genetics are much simpler
for those two lineages.
Because you don't have
the recombination.
AUDIENCE: So why is the
mitochondria-- I mean,
you say that it's the
most obvious thing.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah--
AUDIENCE: I've never heard that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, OK, right.
So--
AUDIENCE: I mean,
we don't have to--
PROFESSOR: OK,
well, you're right.
So basically the situation
is that we have cells,
and most of the genome
is in the nucleus.
But then, but the
mitochondria actually
have their own
mitochondrial DNA.
And then the issue is,
OK, well, what happens?
You know, here's the birds
and the bees talk for you
guys, all right?
Right, so the sperm
comes, fertilizes the egg.
And the vast majority
of the mitochondria
come from, or were
in the egg, as
compared to the
mitochondria from the sperm.
And I don't-- does anybody
know if any of the sperm
mitochondria
actually contribute?
Are they selectively-- does
something happen to them?
AUDIENCE: They don't have any.
PROFESSOR: Oh, they
just don't have any?
All right, whoo.
All right, well, OK.
OK, well that
solves that problem.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
PROFESSOR: Is that not your--
all right, well-- all right,
this is the kind of thing that
somebody could maybe Wikipedia
this while we're going.
But that's the
basic idea, though.
All right, does anybody have
any questions about these two
statements?
Probability that A fixes,
probability that B fixes?
Incidentally, you should be
able to draw-- these are random.
From this point moving forward,
am I more likely-- OK, so
given where i is here, am I
more likely to fix B or A?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: B.
PROFESSOR: B. Does that
mean that my first step is
more likely to be in the
direction of B than in A?
Yes or no.
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
OK, so this is a random lock.
All right, it doesn't
always take steps,
but sometimes it goes
up and then down.
All right, so it's going
to- now I'm-- you know,
I understand it's not
to-- you know, whatever.
OK.
But the idea is
that once it hits
0 or 1 here in terms
of the fraction,
then you stay where you are.
These are absorbing boundaries.
But every now and then
it's going to hit there.
Before we get going
too much more in this,
I want to mention something
about time in this model.
Because time is a little
bit of a funny entity here.
So here's the question.
How long-- and long is
funny-- but how long
does one-- I don't know.
Do we want to call this
an iteration or a cycle?
On iteration of the model?
And what I mean by that is
that in units of something that
would be like real time,
you know what I mean?
Is it a second, a
generation time-- so this
would be like a cell
generation time.
Or don't know, something.
OK, I'll give you 15 seconds.
Can you guys all read this?
Seconds, generation time, N
times generation time, or 1
over N times generation time.
AUDIENCE: What do
we want [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well
let's say that I--
let's just imagine that
I was using this to model
the dynamics of
the neutral drift
dynamics of some bacteria
in my test tube in the lab.
Right, so let's say I have
one of these tubridostats.
So I-- question is,
how long does this
last in the units of-- right.
Or equivalent, how
many iterations
do I have to go to get through
some period of time in the lab.
So I grow my bacteria
in my turbidostat, say.
And I do it for 100 hours.
Now your advisor says,
OK, go do a simulation,
so you get something.
And your advisor goes, all
right, do a simulation, use
the Moran process.
You guys are going
to be doing this,
so this is not
entirely hypothetical.
But right, so your advisor
says, go simulate this process.
Right?
So the question is,
how many iterations
do you have to do to make it
equivalent to that 100 hours
that you did in the lab?
How do you-- how do
you make a connection
between a model, well,
this model, and something
that actually happens
in your laboratory?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, all right, so we got a
majority of the group agreeing
that it's going to be D. Can
somebody just say why this is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
one cell [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so
each iteration, there's
only one cell out of N that
actually divide, right?
And that means that if you want,
like for example, everybody
to have had a chance,
roughly, to divide,
you need to go N iterations.
And it also makes
sense, if you ask--
let's imagine you have a test
tube with a million bacteria.
Now it's going to take some
time before one of them divides.
Now the question is, if
you had 10 million bacteria
in your test tube,
you have to wait 1/10
as long before the
first one divides.
So the amount of real
time that elapses
in each one of these
iterations goes as 1 over N,
where N is the population size.
So I got some unhappy
looks, so that means that I
expect an unhappy question.
Maybe.
OK, well, if you don't
ask the question,
then in the teaching
evaluations you're
not allowed to write
that you did not
like the explanation of
time in the Moran process.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Well, that worked.
A little bit too well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question, just a clarification.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So an
iteration is when
one cell or thing increases?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, an iteration in this
model is both of these things.
So it's a birth, and a
death, or a replacement.
So it's one duration here,
another-- so each iteration
involves one birth
and one replacement.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is
one generation time?
Is that when the
population [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right, so
the generation time
is the typical
time that it takes
for one of these
individuals to give birth
to another individual.
So in the case of the cells,
it might be half an hour.
I'm going to try to leave this
up just so that you guys can
continue to look a bit.
So I want to say just
something about this idea
of a molecular clock
while we're here.
All right, so now that
we've said something
about how much time is
actually elapsing here,
we can think a little
bit about the rate--
now we want to allow mutations.
So let's assume that there is
a mutation rate or probability.
Mu is the probability
of a mutation.
And we're going to say
this is a neutral mutation.
And this is per
division, or per birth.
So the idea is that
when-- all right,
we might start out with
just all A individuals
in the population.
But then an A individual
will give-- OK,
here is the mother
cell, the original A.
And the mother
cell, for now, we'll
assume just doesn't ever mutate.
But that the daughter
cell has a probability,
mu, of being a new type,
say B. And we often
call this a mutation rate, but
it's a probability per birth.
So what we want
to know is what is
the what we want to
calculate is what's
the rate at which new
neutral mutants both appear
and then fix in the population.
So what we're asking about
is, from the standpoint of us
as scientists, we do sequencing
of different lineages,
say humans and chimpanzees.
And we're looking at the
accumulation of these, what
we think are neutral mutations.
Question is, how many neutral
mutations do we expect to see?
So we need to know the rate
that these things happen.
So this is the rate of
fixation of neutral mutations,
and so this is somehow the
rate of neutral evolution.
There are two steps in here.
What are the two things
that have to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right,
needs to appear.
So we'll call this the
rate of appearance.
And then what else
do we need to know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm
sorry, what's that?
AUDIENCE: Population size.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
the population size.
And why are you saying that?
Or what's-- I mean, the
population size is certainly
going to be relevant, but
I guess the question is,
will the rate of
neutral evolution,
the rate in which you see
neutral mutants in a lineage,
will that be just equal to this,
or do we need to multiply it
by something else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
And it's a rate of fixation.
We'll say it's really kind
of a probability of fixation.
Because there's some
rate per unit time.
Maybe even like real
time in terms of number
of generations in real time.
But we need to know the
probability that it fixes.
Great.
So let's-- all right,
we're going to do--
we're going to do a very
detailed calculation here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just
curious, [INAUDIBLE] for this
probability [INAUDIBLE]
time is completely left out
of the picture,
so in principle--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --it could
take a very long time.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: But we don't take
this into account because--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So for now, let's just assume
that the rate of appearance
of these is small,
so that you don't
have to worry about
different mutants competing
against each other.
We're going to
spend a lot of time
on Thursday talking
about this phenomenon
of clonal interference, when
multiple mutant lineages are
coexisting and perhaps
competing in a population.
But for simplicity for now,
what we're just going to assume
is that there's a
separation of time scales.
Right?
Which means that the rate at
which these neutral mutants
appear in the population
is very small compared
to the 1 over the time that
it takes for the fixation
to occur.
So what we want is what's
the rate of appearance
here in units of real time.
What are the things that
are going to appear here?
AUDIENCE: Rate of mutation.
PROFESSOR: All right,
rate of mutation,
mu, times population size.
And that's just because
a larger population
will experience a larger rate
of these mutants appearing
in the population.
And it's a linear.
And that's actually
just-- that is, indeed,
the rate of appearance.
And the probability of
fixation of each one?
AUDIENCE:
[? Excuse me, ?] but it
doesn't have the unit of rate.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
OK, so this is-- OK so
we have to actually--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] times
is that per iteration?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is per, this is per-- so
this is a rate per generation.
So I guess I'd define
mu as the probability--
so this is all in units of
per generation, basically.
Because mu is a per.
AUDIENCE: Generation
or iteration?
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
make sure that I--
mu-- this is a generation.
Because if we have-- right.
So let's say that, for example,
there's 10 to the 6 individuals
here, and the mutation
rate is-- yeah.
All right, probability
of fixation was what?
AUDIENCE: 1 over N.
PROFESSOR: 1 over
N. So this is great.
Because this is saying that
the rate at which you expect
neutral mutants to actually
appear in the population,
in terms of like,
in terms of fixing,
if you were to sequence
along a lineage,
that it is independent
of the population size.
And it's given by
the rate of mutation.
But what you expect
is it's on-- it should
be on a per generation basis.
So this thing is perhaps useful
in several different ways.
And there are some subtleties,
like always, to this.
If you go out and you
measure the rates of fixation
of neutral mutants,
what you find
is that it's not really constant
on a per generation basis.
But more on a-- maybe even
closer on a per actual year
basis, say.
In particular,
this would predict
that if organisms have
the same mutation rate,
I'd say roughly maybe
humans and mice.
But yet humans and mice have
very different generation
times.
By [INAUDIBLE].
Then you would expect
the rate of accumulation
of neutral mutants in the human
population on a per year basis
to be much lower than mice.
But that's not true.
We'll get into a bit
later why that might be.
But I just want to highlight
that that's-- that this model
is very simple.
And it predicts something
that is too simple, maybe.
But at least it's
saying that there's
some sense in which the
population size is not
as relevant as you might have
thought it was going to be.
And at least within
a particular lineage,
if you're talking
about the accumulation
of neutral mutations
along humans,
for example, then you can say,
maybe that's roughly constant.
It gets very-- it
gets very tricky.
I mean, if you look at
the rate of accumulation
of neutral mutants in
one protein in humans,
it's at a different rate than
another protein in humans.
So everything is complicated.
But at least each-- along
each of these proteins,
maybe it still is roughly
some sort of clock,
because it accumulates
mutations at some rate that's
roughly linear with time.
Of course, it's hard to imagine
how any process like this
can not go with time like that.
But at least this is
potentially a useful thing.
And indeed, when you
read about studies
from sequences
trying to estimate
the time since the
last common ancestor,
this is the category
of technique
that is the basis for that, is
that you're just counting up
how many neutral mutations
appeared along these
along these different lineages.
And I think that there are a
number of really fascinating
things that you
can try to address
with this kind of
molecular clock.
And I'll maybe bring
up one of them.
Incidentally, I'm not a huge
fan of memorizing things.
But for both size
scales, and time scales,
and so forth, I really very much
do like the idea of everybody
having memorized
a few sign posts.
Because that way, when
you hear something new,
you have some way
of interpreting
whether it's big, or
small, or something else.
So for example, the time
since the last common ancestor
between humans and chimpanzees.
Does anybody have
any sense of-- well,
I'll actually have us vote,
because I think it's useful.
In case you're off by
many orders of magnitude,
that you make-- OK.
So the last common
ancestor, human, chimpanzee.
And incidentally,
this is something
that people do
argue a lot about.
But it's within a factor
of two of something.
So I'm going to go ahead
and make some-- so hold on.
I just want to make sure I get
my-- well, 7 times 10 to the 6.
All right.
All right, I'll
give you 10 seconds
to orient yourself
relative to other things
that you might know
about the world.
OK, ready, three, two, one.
All right, we got--
that's interesting.
OK, yes.
I would say it's kind of
uniformly distributed-- oh.
It's pretty unified.
There are a minority
of-- not very many E's.
But I would say that the other
things are pretty-- it's maybe
peaked around here.
I don't want to get into
any biblical debates here.
But right, OK.
So what are some
things that if we
have a timeline of the world.
OK, this is going to be a
flash course in-- all right.
OK, here's, here I am,
and I'm unhappy because we
don't know when humans
and chimps-- all right.
So this is us.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So let's say-- we
could start with-- you
want to start with earth?
OK.
Four and a half billion.
This might be on a
logarithmic scale, somehow.
So we're going to-- just to
space things out a little bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, you
know, the universe is what,
13 ish billion years?
I don't know.
People are calculating
with these-- 13 billion,
four and a half billion,
you know earth congeals,
it's hot, whatever.
All right, so life gets started,
maybe, a billion years later.
AUDIENCE: 3.9 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 3.9 sounds
like a fine number.
Wait, what did you vote
for human and chimpanzee?
You're very specific
on this one.
AUDIENCE: I actually voted
for 3.5 times [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, all right.
So you're-- you want to get
involved in this actual debate.
OK, that's why.
I just want to--
yeah, now I'm going
to be stuck doing the linear
and logarithmic scaling of how
I want to-- this is
going to some sort
of funny logarithmic
scaling from here to here.
So dinosaurs-- all right,
60 some million years ago.
Right, so, say bye
to the dinosaurs.
Dinosaurs.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
explosion was before that.
Yeah, I don't-- OK,
it's-- OK, all right.
All right, so this is
around human chimp.
And indeed, people argue
about whether it's five or 10.
But you know, given
that we were uniformly
distributed across
this number, we
shouldn't be nit picky
about the left one.
Right, OK.
And agriculture was
maybe 12,000 years ago.
Some sense of things.
AUDIENCE: B is good for
human and Neanderthal,
and homo erectus.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, human
and Neanderthals, right.
That's-- 70, OK, let's say yeah.
This is when-- right.
AUDIENCE: Common ancestor
was definitely [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, common
ancestor was before.
But in terms of interbreeding,
was sort-- all right.
So this was the interbreeding,
if you want to read that paper.
But human chimp is here.
Around seven million years.
And it's not that this is
the number that's magical,
that you have to memorize.
But I think that you
should have some event
in the history of the world
at each logarithmic spacing.
Just so that you-- when you hear
about when something happened
you know kind of
vaguely where to put--
where to put something.
Otherwise it just
doesn't mean anything.
One of my favorite examples
of how the molecular clock was
used to come up with
something that I think
is pretty neat
and nontrivial, is
to try to answer this
question of when humans
started wearing clothing.
So this is, a priori,
not very obvious.
Right?
Because we know we have
evidence for clothing
maybe 30,000 years ago.
And there are needles that
were used for clothing.
There were-- and some of these
little figurines, at least
some fraction of the figurines,
like fertility goddess
kind of thing, some fraction of
them have some clothing, right?
So then it suggests
that there were clothes.
But the question is, before that
it's actually rather difficult
to know when we started
wearing clothes, right?
Apparently, we lost
our body hair something
like a million years ago.
So you might say, oh,
maybe that's around
when we started wearing clothes.
Of course a lot of animal hide
and so forth wouldn't last.
So there's not any
archaeological evidence
of this.
And so is anybody aware
of how researchers
have used the molecular
clock ideas in order
to try to answer this question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
this is amazing.
So you use lice.
There have been a number
of studies doing this,
and apparently, there was
a researcher in Germany,
who was at the Max Planck
Institute for genomics
or something, and his son
came home with a note saying--
and actually this
happened to me recently,
they got an email that
there's a lice outbreak
to stay out of
preschool, so watch out
when you're going
by the play area--
so he got this note back from
his son's preschool that said,
oh yeah, there's
a lice outbreak,
so this is what you
have to watch out for.
But it said, oh, there's a
different species of lice
that inhabits our
clothing as our hair.
All right, so I'd say this
is one of those things
that you could just read that
and say, oh, well whatever.
Or if you're a
geneticist you read that
and say, oh, I can use this to
figure out when humans started
wearing clothes, right?
Because presumably
the species that
specializes in living in our
clothing was probably not there
or had not yet speciated
before we had clothes.
Course, you can imagine
ways that this could fail,
but it's a neat hypothesis.
So then you can go
and you can basically
sequence the species of lice
that lives in our clothing as
compared to the kind
that lives in our hair,
and you can ask, how many
neutral mutations accumulated
along these different lineages.
Now, you can imagine that
based on, since we just
did this very nice
study, we know
that it should be
more than 30,000 years
and it should be less than 7
million, probably, hopefully.
Although, it's always possible
that our ancestral state was
wearing clothes and
that the chimpanzees
stopped wearing clothes.
But we'd be surprised
if that were the case.
All right, so this is
basically just asking
about head lice
versus clothing lice.
And the original study by
this researcher Max Planck
estimated 70,000 years, but then
just a couple years ago there
was another publication
from a professor
at the University of Florida
that estimated 170,000.
So there still is
a fair range, but I
guess the most recent estimate
we'd have to say is 170,000.
Which is neat.
I don't know-- it's
not that it changes,
necessarily, how I go
about my daily life,
but I really love this idea
that it's a very basic question
that your toddler son might
ask you-- something that you'd
think that might be totally
unknowable in the sense
that we would never have any
way of getting any estimate all,
right?
But using some clever
theoretical ideas together
with data on this accumulation
of neutral mutations
allows one to at least make a
ballpark estimate of something
that there's no physical
record of except
in the DNA of our louses.
Is that a word?
AUDIENCE: It's lice.
PROFESSOR: It's just lice?
All right.
Are there any questions
about this point?
So this is all neutral
mutation, but of course we'd
like to move beyond
these neutral mutations
to try to understand how
non-neutral mutations spread.
I'm not going to
do the derivation,
because the derivation
is in your book,
and you just read about it.
But I do want to just make
sure that we understand what
this equation is telling us.
So first of all we're
going to assume that A
has some relative fitness r.
So r is defined as basically
the relative fitness of of A,
or the fitness of A divided
by the fitness of B.
So r is greater than 1 means
that A is advantageous.
Less than 1 means
it's deleterious.
And what we're
told is that x sub
i, which is the
probability that A fixes,
is equal to this expression.
If A fixes, given
i A individuals
and N minus i B individuals.
AUDIENCE: So I guess that
this assumes that they die
at the same rate [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
The assumption is that we're
placement is unbiased, purely
random, and it's only birth that
is different by a factor of r.
And so I think that this
is, on one level, wonderful.
It's kind of a simple
expression describing
a lot of information
of the dynamics
of the stochastic process.
On another level, the problem
is that you look at it,
and I think it's easy to have
like absolutely zero intuition
for what this thing does.
So what I always like to do when
a student comes to my office
and says, oh I derived
something great for our project.
You take a few
limits to get a sense
of what's going on with it.
At half-time you find
that it's not true.
But at least it's a way
of developing intuition
for what's happening.
All right, so what are limits
that this thing should behave--
AUDIENCE: It should
be 0 if there's no A.
PROFESSOR: Right, so x of
0 should be equal to 0,
is what you're saying.
If you have 0
individuals, you should
have 0 probability of fixing,
independent of your fitness,
right?
All right, that sounds like
a reasonable thing to check.
And does it work?
So r to the 0 is equal to 1.
So that's 1, so
it's 1 minus 1-- 0.
Yep.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: r goes to
infinity independently
of what you start with in step
zero, then you expect A to fix?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the limit of xi for
any i other than 0--
as r goes to infinity,
this should be equal to 1.
All right, so let's see.
If r goes to infinity, you get
0-- this is also 0-- 1 divided
by 1 is equal to 1-- all right.
Did everybody agree with that?
And that makes sense just that
if A is just super, super fit,
then it should fix.
And of course,
what's tricky here
is that r has to be surprisingly
large before this thing ends up
being true.
This limit is great, and
it's correct and true,
but it's also a
little bit dangerous
because-- well we'll see
that even things that you
think of as being very
beneficial mutations typically
do not fix.
So this is the danger, but at
least the limit is still true.
Any other limits that we
think ought to happen?
AUDIENCE: If an i goes to N?
PROFESSOR: An i goes to N?
OK, right.
This is the opposite
of this one.
This is just saying that if
you already have fixed then
you fixed.
Indeed, if i is equal
to N-- that works.
Any other limits that you
believe should be true,
think should be true?
AUDIENCE: The one we already
checked for r equals one?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Indeed.
So if it's neutral-- so the
limit as r goes to 1 of xi
should be equal to what?
AUDIENCE: i/N.
PROFESSOR: Should be
equal to i/N. So this one
is a little bit less
obvious, because if you
set r equal to 1, does this
mean that it's equal to 0?
And what's the problem?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Well, OK, but even
that statement's not true.
It's not even
necessarily close to 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
L'Hopitals?
PROFESSOR: Right.
This is the L'Hopitals.
There was another
context already
were L'Hopitals came up, right?
Maybe?
OK, so the problem is that
if you set r equal to 1 here,
then you get 0.
So then you think,
oh, the answer is 0.
But you have to be more careful
than that, because this also
is equal to 0.
And so L'Hopital's-- L-H-
-- is it above the H?
AUDIENCE: No, that looks right.
PROFESSOR: Is it good?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right.
You're French, right?
I mean, sort of.
He's from Quebec, so I don't
know what that question--
how it's interpreted.
So this [INAUDIBLE]
looks all right.
See, what you just
have to do is then
you take the
derivative with respect
to r for both the numerator
and the denominator,
and then you see what ha--
but you take the limit again.
And sometimes you have
to apply L'Hopital's rule
multiple times, right?
So what we write here is this
is the limit as r goes to 1,
and we take the derivative of
the numerator respect to r.
So we get out an i, 1 over
r to the i plus 1, maybe?
And here we get out an N.
All right, so we took the
derivatives back to r here.
But we left it as a
limit because we might
need to apply it again, right?
Just because after you
take the derivative
you're not guaranteed that
it's going to work out fine,
but in this case it does.
Because already,
this limit, we're
allowed to just set equal to
1 because nothing blows up.
So this is indeed
equal to i/N. N.
And the important point here
is that it's not necessarily
approximately equal to 0.
It could be anywhere
between 0 and 1
depending what i and N are.
PROFESSOR: So that means
that this expression here
captures the dynamics,
actually, for all i, r,
N within the Moran process.
This thing is simply
just true in this model.
There are no approximations yet.
There is, however,
one approximation
that is very useful
to make, which
is the approximation
of what happens
when r is approximately 1.
In particular what
we're going to ask
is, if we define something
called a selection
coefficient, that is
1 plus s, the idea
here is that in many
cases-- well for Thursday
we're going to read
a paper that I think
this is quite interesting.
And where they were
analyzing the appearance
of these mutations
that would allow
bacteria to survive in some
environment to do better.
And typical selection
coefficients
here are kind of 1% to 3%.
So the mutations that appear and
that allow one of these cells
to do better in this
new environment,
convert an advantage that was
on the order of 1% or 2%, or so.
Which means that s here
would be like 0.01, 0.02.
Which means that for basically
all the situations that you
see in the laboratory and
so forth, what you really
want to know is what
happens for small s.
So for s, much less than 1.
So where r is
approximately equal to 1.
And in this case, we
can say xi, well--
and we actually are going to
want to ask about x sub 1.
So that's a 1 now.
And the reason for that
is that we want to know,
are there some rate
that new mutations
will appear in the population?
When they appear they'll be
present in a single individual,
and we want to know what
is the probability that one
individual-- let's say
has a beneficial mutation,
well, the probability it'll
fix-- so we want to know
is for s, much less than
1, but larger than 0.
So far, it's a beneficial
mutation of modest effect.
What's the probability
that it will fix?
Well the idea here
is that r to the N
is going to be much larger
than 1, because N is often
a big population.
Now in that situation,
this is just
approximately equal to 1 over r.
And r, we've already decided
it can be expressed as 1
plus the selection coefficient.
Now this is something
that you want
to be able to simplify
in your sleep.
1 divided by 1 plus
s is approximately
equal to 1 minus 1 minus s.
And this is indeed
approximately equal to s.
This is saying that
in the Moran process,
if a beneficial mutation
appears in the population
with selection code coefficient
s, that might be 1% to 3%,
then it has a 1% to 3%
probability of surviving.
Because this is the
probability of fixing,
but in this situation
fixation and survival
are the same thing,
because we're just
considering this one mutation.
So it's the only
thing that we're
considering is the fate of this
one mutation of the population.
We're going to assume
for now that you
can't get new mutations in the
population to compete with.
And then either you
go extinct, or you
take over the population.
And what's surprising
here is that even
if it's a fact that you think
it was big, like 3%, 4%.
I would love to get
such a mutation.
But still, in a population
in the Moran process,
or really in any
other model like this,
it will typically go extinct.
Now, it's worth
saying that depending
upon the model
that you're using,
you'll get different
numbers in here.
In this case, the probability
of fixation or survival
is 1 times s.
But in some other
models and it depends
on the branching process.
It could be two times s.
But it's something of
order unity times s.
AUDIENCE: And so we say that
if s is equal to 0, then x of 1
should be--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
assume that s is much,
much greater than 1/N?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So what we've assumed
is that this is true
and that I think that's
actually already sufficient.
And indeed, you can go and
you can do the expansion
and find what x sub 1 should
be equal to in general here.
And for small s, but
including the possibility
that it's very-- I'm sorry-- for
small s but not super small s.
It's a matter of what
you're comparing to.
And you end up
getting 1/N plus s/2.
And this is for s times
N much less than 1.
And indeed, this
is the definition
of what we mean
by nearly neutral.
Because up to now we've been
talking about neutral mutations
as if they just had to be
exactly, exactly neutral,
but then really, that probably
doesn't actually literally
exist.
But if a mutation appears and
it only changes your fitness
by one part in 10
to the minus 30,
then it is equivalent to being
a truly neutral mutation.
But the way that you
quantify that is this thing.
s times N. You want
to know whether it's
larger or smaller than 1.
So for example if you plot x
sub 1 as a function of s-- 0,
right?
It crosses 1 over N here.
Now, it's going to have
a slope here-- s over 2--
but then it kind of goes up.
It eventually hits this--
this is just the s line--
because if s is
much less than 1,
yet s times N is
much larger than 1,
then x1 is approximately
equal to s.
And then over here, this
goes down exponentially.
But the statement is that if
s times N is much less than 1,
then the mutation acts
essentially as if it's neutral.
So then you can
just work with that,
whereas, if s times N
is much larger than 1,
then you end up--
it's not guaranteed
that it's going to fix, but it's
much larger than a probability
of 1/N. Whereas down
here, it becomes
very unlikely to fix once
s times N is larger than 1
on the deleterial side.
Are there any questions
about what's going on here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
about that factor of 1/2.
[INAUDIBLE] seems like we didn't
get it over here when we had N
equals--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, sorry.
And indeed, when I did this
calculation originally,
I was very confused, because
I thought it should be that.
But what you see is
that if you plot this,
the slope here, which is
the 1/2, is less than slope
over here, which is 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, what's
funny is, I actually spent,
like, hours, trying
to figure out
where I had made my mistakes.
No, but I think that
if you just draw it,
I think it's all consistent.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I mean, I'm
plotting the entire curve,
analytically, perfectly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's just
that what we know,
is that it behaves
like this around here,
and like s up here, and
I've just connected them--
it probably doesn't answer
your question but it--
So I think we have just
enough time to say something
about this Muller's
ratchet idea.
Verbally, can a deleterious
mutation, s less than 0,
can it fix in a population?
Yes or no?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is greater than 0.
Now it's, very unlikely to
fix if the negative s times N
is much larger than 1.
But for small size
populations, you
could actually fix relatively
deleterious mutations.
So the idea is that
for small populations,
it's easy to accumulate
deleterious mutations.
And indeed, This is related
to something called a mutation
accumulation assay.
So if you take a
population of bacteria
or other microorganism--
so you grow up
your bacteria in a test tube.
And so you have a
bunch of bacteria.
So now there's selection acting
in here, because the faster
dividing cells are spreading.
However, what you do is that
you then plate them as colonies.
And these colonies each
started as single cells.
Then what you do
is you just take
a random cell, a random colony,
that came from a single cell,
and you grow it up here.
Or you could just replay
directly if you like.
And then you just
repeat this process.
The idea is that you've
picked a random cell
from this population that
you allowed it to grow up,
and so you've kind of removed
the effects of selection
in here.
So when you pick a
random colony here,
maybe that colony got
some weird mutation
that decreased its fitness,
but it wasn't really selected
against because you
just kind of picked
one of these colonies randomly.
So this kind of process
is a way of reducing
what's known as the effective
population size-- N effective.
So when populations are
not constant in time,
but instead oscillate
or fluctuate,
then in many cases the dynamics
or the strength of this drift,
or the stochastic stuff,
that could be characterized
by some ineffective.
And of course, depending
on which variable
or which quantity
you're trying to study,
you might have a slightly
different N effective.
But the point is that if you
have fluctuating population
sizes, then the relevant
population size for thinking
about these sorts
of ideas, is often
towards the smaller
side of the range
of the fluctuating population.
So you're kind of dominated by
how small the bottleneck gets.
And here, you're kind of
going through a single cell
bottleneck, so that leads
to a very small N effective,
and it allows for
the accumulation
of deleterious mutations.
Now, we'll say something more
about this Muller's ratchet
idea, because in the
field of evolution,
I'd say one of the big
overriding questions
is trying to understand
the evolutionary advantages
of sexual reproduction.
Because of this famous
twofold cost of sex.
That it seems that
an asexual population
should be able to grow
twice as fast as a sexually
reproducing population, because
the males are not giving birth.
So it's a huge cost associated
with sexual reproduction.
The question is, why is it that
so many organisms engage in it?
And one of the explanations
that's been proposed
is this Muller's
ratchet idea, that it
may alleviate this accumulation
of deleterious mutations.
We'll talk more about
how this works out,
maybe quantitatively,
and the other proposals
and so forth later, but
you may, over the course
of your studies, come across
this Muller's ratchet vis-a-vis
the question of
sexual reproduction.
So I just wanted you
to know that there
is this discussion out there,
about how sexual reproduction
may allow for the separation
of these beneficial and
deleterious mutations
that would otherwise
accumulate in the population.